I support him because I'm a Christian
it's it's rather simple you don't I mean
look the idea that I mean I think you
you know this right that there are
people and we see this on the Left today
no matter what you do they'll find
what's wrong with it
Trump has you know has made this so much
worse just by being Trump he's he's
driven people insane so that if he says
one plus one equals two they're gonna
say I don't know about that and some
people say it might not and in a quantum
universe that's a lot of baloney and
he's too stupid to understand what a
quantum universe is right all right so
this is gonna be a hell of a segue watch
how I do it with all of that cultural
stuff you're talking about in the
academic elites
you've written some children's book
books about Donald Trump yeah there's I
sense a connection there these are not
well coincidences I actually I have to
sort of correct you and and this is my
fault because I I have let this go
without correcting people and no I'll
tell you what I've written 30 children's
books over the years right but I've also
written a lot of humor I was the the
humor the editor of the humor magazine
at Yale I wrote a parody of the old
Ripley's Believe It or Not books with
st. Martin's Press like 20 years ago
I've written a lot of humor and when I
do public speaking and stuff there's
just a lot of comedy and goofing around
on my radio program you know some people
think of me as as funny so I had this
idea when Trump was that's a good title
for a book that's a good title for a
book some people think of me as funny
I'm not gonna use it I give that to you
no no so I'll make you know but but the
funny but but the thing is that I like
humor I like satire I mean I'm even
published humor in The New Yorker and in
the Atlantic and stuff you know I've
loved that kind of thing and when Trump
was elected I said to the guy my dear
friend Tim Raglan who lives in Kansas
and he and I have done a number of books
together he's a genius illustrator the
stuff we've done together is just it's
stunning but I said to him Tim you know
you're the one that convinced me to look
differently at Trump when I was still
kind of like I don't know about that guy
I'm a New Yorker and you know he's sort
of vulgar and I'm a Christian I don't
know he's not my first pick and he he
kind of had me look at him differently
and I said Trump is like he's like a
folk hero he's like out of one of these
books that I've written with Tim Raglan
like he's larger than life like a
cartoon figure and I said attempt him
we need to do like a children's book
about a character like a Trump character
but it's really adult satire in the form
of a children's book right now for
example I wrote a lullaby book actually
for kids called it's time to sleep my
love right
some guy decided to parody that book and
use the title go the F to sleep okay now
that's sold a lot more than my book but
the point is it looks like a children's
book but it's obviously meant for adults
the thing with my book Donald drains
this one I just happen to have a copy
here Donald drains the swamp right is
that even though it's aimed at adults
because their sophisticated humor for
example the turtle just happens to look
like Mitch McConnell that's a
coincidence because all turtles are but
but the point is that when you're
talking about the swamp and all the
senses a lot of political humor but
because there's nothing nasty in it it
works for kids so people often say it's
a kids book as kids but technically it's
it's an adult humor book it's a novelty
book it's a satire book and adults are
gonna get all the jokes kids aren't
gonna get the jokes they don't know who
a assi is and they don't know that
bernie is a communist and they're you
know so so we've written three of these
books but the big reason that we did
them as I said the one thing we
conservatives tend to be bad at is
creating culture we talk about politics
all the time but in terms of sitcoms or
you know children's books or the world
of publishing it tends to be taken over
by the left the left really has you know
the long march to the institutions
academia publishing journalism it's all
very
very leftist and I said I want to create
something that's fun for people who
actually like this president and of
course the reason he's a caveman is sort
of meant to be funny because he is kind
of a caveman you kind of think caveman
they see a problem they fix the problem
they don't know that you're not supposed
to do it that way they just want to fix
the problem like they're good guys and
they just do it so it's not really
making fun of him but there's there's
there's a lightness to it for people who
think of him as somewhat of a caveman
but metaxas I can see the commenters
already in the future and they're gonna
say wait a minute
how can this intellectual Christian
talking about Jesus right right support
the caveman how can it possibly be I
support him because I'm a Christian it's
it's rather simple you don't I mean look
the idea that I mean I think you you
know this right that there are people
and we see this on the left today no
matter what you do they'll find what's
wrong with it
Trump has you know has made this so much
worse just by being Trump he's he's
driven people insane so that if he says
one plus one equals two
they're gonna say I don't know about
that and some people say it might not
and in a quantum universe that's a lot
of baloney and he's too stupid to
understand what a quantum universe is
right like you can definitely racist
it's also right it's all salts we forgot
to mention cuz of that saying it's
racist so yeah I think that the reason
that I support Trump is it's kind of
weird actually
I was writing this humor piece for The
New Yorker called more Trump Bible
verses because there was that you know
contra tomp about him not remembering
something to the bite I found the whole
thing hilarious right and so I did a
whole thing of like tweets of Bible
verses that they're kind of trumpian you
know like I don't know if I can remember
any of them right now but you know like
a good wife who can find I found three
you know whatever I you know there was
just all these Bible verses that we have
some dim memory of and then you know
sort of a trump occation of it anyway
I was writing it for The New Yorker this
is totally true I I found myself almost
like a comedian because I have written a
lot of comedy like you're writing for a
voice you're writing for like I'm
writing for Bob Hope or I'm writing for
Jackie Mason and you kind of find that
voice and you find that rhythm and I
found myself having kind of an affection
for him in the way that you would for an
uncle that he's not you know politically
correct he he doesn't he there's a lot
of stuff about him that you know
wouldn't work among your friends but you
love him and you know he's a good man
and you know he loves his country and he
would fight and die for his country and
if you're in trouble you want him around
he's a goodies good but he's reference
and he's got a lot of things and you say
please don't say that whatever you do
please don't say that when my friends
are over they they're not going to
understand that you know and I I began
to see that side of him and then I also
realized that because I grew up in a
working-class environment he speaks to
the working-class Martin Luther about
whom I've also written had a similar
ability you know even though you know
Trump went to Wharton and is obviously
an instinctive genius there's no
question about it but he has an ability
to connect with the working class and a
big part of that is humor and hyperbole
and I began to hear him differently and
I began to think wow the cultural elites
they don't get that language it's like
he may as well be speaking Japanese they
don't get it and so I began to
appreciate him more and more but I have
to say that if anything ever revealed to
me how pathetic the Republican Party had
become you know when when they turned
against him the way that that he did I
mean his ability to see the problem in
China for example we'll just talk about
a minor thing really minor right 1.3
billion people I mean the the the level
of seriousness that our leaders ought to
have accorded China over the last three
decades is is so huge and they basically
ignored it while it grew into
monster Trump if he did nothing else
diagnosed the problem 30 years ago has
been talking about it for 30 years and
is now rather effectively doing a number
of things to deal with this problem how
much money is he making a lot less than
hunter Biden is making on China I don't
see him getting anything out of it
except he feels it's the right thing for
America so it's things like that that's
just one but I mean he has been very
staunchly pro-life and staunchly
religious liberty and these are things
that have concerned me deeply his his
willingness to stand up for Cavanaugh I
would bet that a lot of Republicans
people that I thought were good guys 10
years ago they would have folded at the
end and so there's there's a lot to
recommend him and you're not supposed to
vote for somebody because you think they
share your theology III don't I don't
really think that's why you elect a
president it would be nice if he did but
you know it's like saying that like that
Pilate is not that great but he loves
Jesus and that Pilate is the best pilot
who ever flew a plane but he's had four
wives and he's been in jail you know
it's people make it sound like it's it's
a simple choice it's not a simple choice
if you're looking for more honest and
thoughtful conversations about politics
instead of non-stop yelling check out
our politics playlist and if you want to
watch full interviews on a variety of
topics watch our full episode playlists
all right over here and to get notified
of all future videos be sure to
subscribe and click the notification
bell